okay so just let me go back to the to
the main point here which is to really
thank Ali for uh this uh for the amount
of work that she has put into this
conference I'm I'm really thrilled to be
here and I am really excited about a day
in which I'm sure I'm going to learn a
lot because as you will discover very uh
quickly uh my knowledge of the world
ends around the Industrial Revolution so
it is uh really thrilling to be to be
here so just to give you a little bit of
context here I am going to plunge this
conversation about assemblies and
lotteries into a sort of a broader
historical context here looking at what
I will uh sort of like Define in a
moment as um instances of historical uh
Collective governance um and so here I
don't really have let me just begin with
a shout out to my collaborators without
uh whom this project would never have uh
existed including Nathan Schneider at
the University of Colorado and one of
our postgraduate Ras Riley Wong who has
done um a bunch of the analysis that I
will present today and a bunch of arrays
at Kings where I work um in this context
in this room I don't have to articulate
uh so much uh the sort of like a
motivating question uh behind the
project which is of course something
along the lines of what Ali has already
articulated uh it's not so much per se
the Saka collapse of of liberal
democracy although that is certainly uh
behind the scenes um it is also just the
sheer surgeon demand uh in spaces for
participation something that I as a
historian particularly historian of
classical Athens have sort of a grown up
uh studying but it is certainly not
something that uh at least until like 10
years ago so to speak uh really uh
permeated the work of politics and and
we could Ali has already shown some
evidence of the sort of like the
steepness of this surge um but also the
variety of instances in which we see uh
sort of a forms of participation sort
like a pop up in modern politics online
and on and offline uh things like
political parties uh registering citizen
permanent institutions like rition
commissions and of course the climate
assemblies that have taken up so much of
the uh sort of like a uh you know um uh
newspaper uh front pages uh in these uh
in in recent years so the sort of a
motivating question for a historian like
me or someone trained in history like me
is that we sort of like a threet a lot
about these uh modern experiments with
participatory uh governance but of
course participatory governance is not a
21st century phenomenon it is something
that is certainly aided by technology
but that did not begin uh in 1990 or
1970 um and so the problem though is
that once you start looking into
Collective governance in an historical
perspective what you get is a pretty
sort of like a um strange story and The
Story begins with the sort of a
suitability for humans uh to live in
small bands of hunter gatherers where
horizontal govern governance was easy of
course for a variety of reasons uh
heterogeneous uh homogeneous preferences
small scale and so on and so forth and
then we see sort like a large scale
Collective governance experiments pop up
uh throughout history uh but in a
particular part of the world right so
this is uh of course classical Athens
and Republican Rome uh the uh um s the
17th century and onward experiences of
early modern Europe uh but of course um
Collective governance uh in historical
perspective is not a a European
phenomenon as this story this very
influential story uh seems to suggest uh
we have plenty of evidence of uh
Collective governance outside of Europe
uh from various disciplines uh
archaeology anthropology some political
science but it is this evidence is
really not systematized and so the
result I believe is that we don't really
have a clear view of under what
conditions Collective governance arises
uh survives or uh Saka flourishes and
when and under what conditions it fails
um so the project that I'm going to be
describing a little bit today before I
delve more specifically into the
question of uh historical assemblies and
the use of the lot um is a project that
looks at uh instances of collective
governance throughout history and across
the world uh which is arguably a
slightly over ambitious uh uh way of
stating what this project is all about
um and I can I can talk a little bit
about the limit and the boundaries of
this uh in the Q&A if people are
interested but the reasons why we're
doing this are twofold uh first again if
we uh sort of like believe the standard
story of collective governance um and
the European evidence that we has for it
uh I think it is fair to say the
theories that we build on uh uh on this
evidence are limited are partial um and
so what we want to do with this evidence
that I will describe in a moment is to
um sort of like a br our theories of
collective governance but the the the
theory and the source of science is not
the whole story um with a bunch of
collaborators were also trying to turn
this data set into a tool that people
the communities online and offline can
actually use uh to build more resilient
self-governing practices uh today and of
course part of the uh sort of me being
here I guess today um is that this data
set among the things can be used to take
a look at for example particular
mechanisms such as a lot so I'm going to
be doing that today but before we get
there um I want to spend a little bit of
time describing the database without
which I think it' be U hard to get the
context um and give you some preliminary
findings from the two years of data
collection that we have uh conducted so
far um I'll spend a little bit of time
describing uh what we know about the use
of the lot which is indeed uh spoiler
alert not so much um and then I'm going
to try to give you a bit of context on
how uh historical assemblies actually uh
got uh things done uh including but also
uh beside the use of the law and then um
Ali sort of like provoked me a bit uh
for this last bit to give you a sense of
like how I use or how I imagine uh this
evidence this historical evidence might
be used in the process of actually
thinking about institution building
today so after a lot of talking about
history we're going to get to the meet
uh at the very end so please stay awake
for that it's going to be great okay so
I'm going to describe I'm going to be
describing for a few minutes what the
data base uh looks like um and this is
uh uh sort of going to include some
definitions so two years of data
collection we've got six communities not
a lot guys but this is what we've got uh
the communities that enter the data set
uh are uh communities that meet at least
one Criterion or necessarily one
Criterion that they have one Collective
governance institution that is an
institution within which a group of more
than one person makes decisions on
behalf of a community uh The crucial uh
Criterion for uh what defines a
collective governance institution is uh
drawn by from the work of David Savage
this is for the S the dorks uh in the
room that are like really into the the
social science behind this if you don't
know who David Savage is it doesn't
matter the idea here is what uh what I I
suppose many of you who are Scholars
will but the bottom line is that the
idea is that participants in these
Collective governance institutions need
to be independent of a higher authority
if it exists and so this is the basic
criteria in uh discriminating between
early democracy and early autocracy in
David's work for those of you who know
what I'm talking about U so six
communities uh within yes please let me
Qui question uh what is Fire Authority
here what are we referring to the
principal or yeah this this would be a
higher authority understood like like a
king or an emperor or um even like a
higher Governor um right and so the idea
here is that if the line of command is
that one of dependency you are resp
responding to your essentially like
implementing rules that come up from a
higher authority that doesn't really
meet the basic
requirements example no no no that would
not be that would not be the case um So
within each Community there are a number
of Institutions some of which are
institutions for Collective governance
some are not and so we're looking
actually at the nesting of collective
governance practices within larger uh
structures um and each institutions has
what we call mechanisms and the
mechanisms are really the nitty-gritty
of how people got things done within the
institutions the the actual rules
lotteries elections uh various types of
um sort of tools that we then further um
uh classified or categorized in
mechanisms that Define access to the
institutions mechanis that mechanisms
that Define decision- making practices
and mechanism that regulate enforcement
practices okay um so this is just to
give you an overview of what we've got
in the data set we have got coverage of
all regions of the world except that of
course uh the evidence from Europe is
preponderant this
is I I doubt that this is ever going to
go away but this is definitely a product
of what the evidence what kind of
evidence is easily uh accessible
essentially by a bunch of undergrads at
King's College London which is a bunch
of evidence from Europe we are now
changing dramatically the way in which
we uh conducted data
collection which is going to bring us in
contact with communities in ious parts
of the world there are not Western
Europe and North America and I can talk
a little bit about that second stage in
the Q&A if anyone is interested but for
the time being what matters here is that
uh what we're trying to do here is
actually again shift the focus of
attention um Beyond uh Europe and to try
to understand what Collective governance
looks what Collective governance looks
like in other places of the world uh
when we look at the communities by Sid
we see this again like relatively uh
broad coverage but a significant cluster
around 10 thou the sort of like the size
that includes memberships between 10,000
and 100,000 participants so not large
but also not tiny uh in historical
perspective um and when you look at the
time we see a clustering of communities
in the first millennium BC and in the
second Millennium ad this again I doubt
is an actual empirical result of the
analysis and it's mostly driven by the
kind of evidence that we have at our
disposal that covers uh the sort of like
usual suspect from the largely uh sort
of a European tradition so we will see
if by looking at other non-european
cases the timeline shifts um with the
evidence um in ter I'm just wanted to
give you a sense of like what these
mechanisms look like so of course this
matters to you because it includes uh
the the you the lotteries um as a
mechanism I will talk about this in a
moment uh of axis as a fundament one of
the primary perhaps mechanism for
accessing in Collective governance
institutions but as you can see uh there
are a number of other mechanisms that
come up in this uh in this data set that
suggest variation uh across uh selection
mechanisms uh we see uh when we look at
decision making mechanisms again a
preponderance of Usual Suspects such as
Council councils and assemblies uh but
we also see uh sort of like the growing
importance of things like deliberation
consensus and representation and we look
at enforcement again uh we see uh courts
and tribunals as the primary bodies for
enforcement procedures but also some
interesting evidence on the use of
scrutinies and uh practices like ticism
and judicial review so this is just to
give you a sense of what what is in this
data set um so as I said we have spent a
a couple of years uh collecting evidence
again a bunch of this evidence is from
Europe we're trying to push that uh sort
of like a push against that but we are
not quite there yet uh we have spent a
good chunk of our summer uh this past
past summer uh looking at exactly what
this database is telling us about
Collective governance and so I'm just
going to be uh mentioning three results
uh which I think are uh uh uh perhaps
like promising enough that I still think
that this work should we continue I
should continue to do this but maybe
this is something that you can uh advise
me um on uh towards the end of this
presentation if you think that this is
there's there's no there's no they are
there so the the the primary finding
that uh seems of relevance is that the
mechanisms that we see operating uh
within uh Collective governance
communities that are in Europe are not
the same as the mechanisms that we see
otherwise uh in in other places of the
world so that is quite interesting this
is just to give you sense of what this
looks like in the correlations there is
a cluster of mechanisms that we
associate with Collective governance
today in the United States uh we tend to
think about Collective governance as
something that has assemblies as we've
heard heard the day councils uh and
things like lotteries THM limits
rotation um these mechanisms are very
familiar to the Western tradition of
collective governance but it turns out
that when we look outside of Europe
these mechanisms cease to be uh present
uh just uh simply and when we uh see see
correlations between Collective
governance outside of Europe and
particular mechanisms we see something
else popping up essentially um these
includes informal s sanctions
consultation procedures
uh popularity in meritocracy and local
councils and blood relations and
meritocracy um in other in and again
like there is not just variation between
Europe and other parts of the world but
also within
non-european uh uh um s locations we see
variation as well and so this is really
for us a um sort of indication that we
should perhaps continue with the data
collection in these other places and try
to figure out what kind of picture we
get of collective governance when we
take a more global perspective on it uh
a couple of more perhaps less sort of
interesting and a little bit boring
findings but please bear with me um
there seems to be an inverted you uh
shaped relationship between size and
duration this is quite interesting
because it seems to push against the
idea that Collective governance
collapses at scale um it seems the what
we find in the data set so far is that
there is a sort of like a sweet spot
where Collective governance communities
seem to last longer again lasting longer
is not necessarily a sign of success
this is problematic but this is what the
data says so far um and uh so we we sort
of uh this seems to be like some sort of
illustrative evidence that suggests that
there is something more interesting
about scale and Collective governance
than what we tend to imagine uh which is
essentially that as scale increases the
probability of collective governance
decreases um the third uh finding that I
wanted to chat to talk about is again
variation by size so this is a similar
uh perhaps result and it again suggests
that there is uh something going on at
the level of different communities of
different sizes seem to be uh operating
through different mechanisms so again
this is perhaps something to keep in
mind as we think about building a
collective governance spaces uh it seems
from the evidence that we've got that uh
different mechanisms like a mechanism
might not apply equally uh to
communities of various sizes and here uh
when we look at the sort of like
mechanisms uh with European cases we see
this clustering of a series of
mechanisms at a particular sort of the
this middle range sizes when we take
Europe out we see a more variation
across uh sizes and again this is uh in
part the problem here is that we don't
have a lot of evidence as I mentioned
about non-european cases we certainly
don't have as robust evidence about
non-european cases but these uh results
are sort of like illustrative of
something that is going on uh in uh sort
of like different parts of the world
that they might tell us something new
about Collective governance uh let me
just stop for a second before I get into
the more meaty part to make sure that a
you have not fallen asleep uh B you uh
still with me and I have not jumped over
uh massive logical
steps good excellent okay so because
this conference is about the lot and
assemblies Ali asked me uh to please uh
sort of like reveal some uh information
about what this uh data set says about
this particular uh topic and it turns
out that again I'm you know very happy
to be contradicted here uh by other
people that are looking at lotteries
more specifically but what emerges in
this particular case of collective
governance communities or communities
operating uh or building Collective
governance spaces uh is that the lot is
not very common um and so I'm going to
try to sort of articulate why that might
be the case and how where where the lot
is common how it was used and this is
going to Echo some of the uh comments
that Ali has already made and then I'm
going to uh try to articulate what else
is going on in historical assemblies in
terms of these access and selection
mechanisms that seems to be more uh
prominent um so again this is a uh when
we talk about lotteries it is in in
historical practice it is worth
distinguishing between various uses of
the lot so we might think about the LW
as a system to allocate res resources uh
Ali has a excellent paper on land
lotteries for example this is not what
I'm looking at uh the lotteries that I'm
looking at here are uh uniquely systems
for access to institutions so there's
system of selection of members of an
institution and from the from the
evidence that I that we have collected
so far the the lot is really not that
common and it only applies to three
cases uh the third of which is I believe
a coding Mistake by one of my Ras and
it's the only one that that is not in
Europe um and so I uh um sort of like a
what the um the database is not a
representative sample or or a or um uh
uh what is the word I'm looking for like
um uh uh
comprehensive view of historical
Collective governance but the evidence
that we see that we have so far really
suggests that the law is infrequent and
fundamentally European uh within uh
Europe uh it was used in a variety of
different ways so this again Echoes
something that uh Ali has already said
uh it is used within the political
process in uh a very different ways and
even within each Community it can be
used in different ways so I'm giving you
two exam the two examples of that uh the
first comes from Venice
Costas question curiosity question uh
would you would you say or would it be a
plausible assumption to say that you see
these lotteries in Venice or in Greek
poish just because you can assure her
degree of preference homogeneity there
so then there would be more easy with
accepting a lottery as opposed to other
more heterogeneous
contexts great that that is that is
possible I don't know I don't think that
the data set at this stage can allow me
to uh reach conclusions partly because
again this is a very small sample it is
the n is equal equals to one anecdotally
or like descriptively or like uh yeah
yeah and again like you know I can talk
about Asian Athens until your eyes pop
out which I'm not going to do today uh
but it is certainly true that I think uh
in the case of Athens in particular uh
compared to like the um I don't want to
be historical here because consider
Athens is a complicated part of part of
the world because if you think about
Athens in terms of what we expect today
representation or inclusion to be of
course Athens was elitist this is
something that Ali mentioned earlier
except that the comparison to Athens was
Persia where no one was participating to
begin with so again it depends really on
where you're standing and so preference
homogeneity in Athens is something that
really is in the eyes of the beholders
or it changes depending on who you ask
if you ask uh sort of like a you know a
modern commentator of course the
Athenians were extremely homogenous in
terms of preferences uh if you're
thinking however in the historical
context particularly given um
heterogeneity in terms of like a you
know associational life uh occupation uh
socio economic status political views
I'll think about Plato um uh that uh
that to me is evidence of preference
heterogenity so again I think this is a
great question but not something that
I'm sure uh this data set could uh uh
thoroughly uh
address Kevin do you have a burning sure
yeah so just just on the preference
homogeneity point one thing maybe you
could if you look at um places of
similar size right that that might give
you some kind of very rough
uh indication of it but you could also
look at the contemporary justifications
of the institution right so um is it
that we have Lottery because we all
think we are equally um we all have
roughly the same views and so really
doesn't matter who occupies the office
in Athens that doesn't seem to be the
case it's more about equality we are all
sort of um we respect everyone equally
everyone should everyone who would like
to have a a place and speak and so forth
is if everybody has the same so you're
right risk aversion might non
monotonically vary because if I know
everybody has the same preference I'm
willing to take the risk Lottery if I
know everybody has very diverse
preferences better to the lottery it's
only the midpoint that I would be
willing to switch from a lottery to
something that I could potentially
control more or I could like in a
situation where I mean I'm 80 60 70%
more strong and I can just think I have
full control of the the power if it to
diver or to homogeneous then the risk
aarion relationship with that might not
be monotonic I that's a hypothesis right
not are you settled with your own
questions okay uh let me just uh
continue so again like I don't think I
um looking at the justification for the
lot is going to be r with problems of EV
what is the evidentiary basis that's
justifying that use um and looking at
size might be interesting but again like
the nend is so small it's going to be
essentially like non-informative but
this is again like if the data
collection processes in the future will
change this picture I think that those
questions will become uh more more
relevant um so again just going back to
these two examples which I think are
pretty illustrative of the range of uses
of the lot um in historical societies
although of course uh these are perhaps
some of the most uh well-known cases uh
just to give you a a a brief sort of
like a comparison between a situation in
which which the law was really folded
into an extremely complex procedure but
at a very high stakes in the political
process so the doger is that highest
auth Authority in Venice between the
11th and the 14th century and the
selection of uh the doer was entrusted
as a gri and Laden summarized In this
passage here to a committee which was
itself selected by a combination of lot
and delegation and the uh the the
process was well like famously
extraordinarily complicated in in nine
steps and so again we see the laot and
this is perhaps a point that is relevant
also for some of the questions in the
round table later the lot here is not
just a sort of like a unique system of
selection that is uh presented as better
or worse or for a particular reasons
depending on the particular sort of like
needs of the society but it is really
part of a much more complex system of
selection uh that is aimed at a variety
of uh outcomes including some of the
outcomes that Ali has uh discussed
particularly uh the the sort of attempt
at eliminating Elite capture by in this
case uh Clans and uh social groups
within the PO of Venice um in Athens the
law was used much more broadly in fact
uh the three of the four main uh
institutions in uh included the use of
the law one way or another the third the
fourth being the assembly that was where
members were selected on a first Comer
Ser basis but um in look look at the
other three uh institu main institutions
in the PO of Athens uh we see that again
like the law was used abundantly and
differentially uh in the council that I
will talk about more in a second uh it
was used for the selection of uh
representative sample of jurors in the
courts it was very interestingly again
for dorks in the room well known uh to
be used on a daily basis for the
selection of jury panels in the Law
Courts uh through the system known as as
Clarian this is the part where like I I
flash you this like ancient system of
randomization that the Athenians used um
and uh in the uh in the in the council
again it was used in a slightly
different way uh that I will talk about
uh uh in in Greater depth uh in a moment
sorry and with the magistrates uh it was
also used for the selection of some
magistrates but um not all so again
within each institutions we see a number
of potentially different selection
processes um and uh variation across
them as well um so this is the part
where the slides were uh uh sort of like
messed up so I wanted to just uh suggest
let's see okay so the point here is that
the lot was not very commonly used based
on my uh data collection among
historical uh cases of historical
communities practicing form of
collective governance so what else is
used uh let's say in historical
assemblies and this again just to give
you a sense of what I mean by historical
assemblies we we coded a variety of them
uh assemblies that operate at the
central level which means the highest
administrative level within a community
and assemblies that operated at the
local level uh so sort of like a
subunits within a community um and we
coded both uh at the local at the
central level assemblies that featured
uh some sort of like a elite uh um a
membership or just a broader citizen
assembly of the kinds that we are uh
discussing uh today
assemblies again this reflects some of
the stuff that I've already discussed
are by and large a European and a little
bit Asian as well phenomenon um and they
are overwhelmingly in the data set uh uh
Central and uh citizen based not
Elite um okay so this is uh just to give
you a sense of what else is going on uh
lot the lot um uh appears so high up in
this uh Matrix largely because it is
used so frequently in Athens and in
other Greek poce so this is actually a
somewhat of a of a false result because
what's driving the the frequency here is
really the sort of a multiple uses that
particularly Greek police made of the
lottery of of lotteries uh what else is
going on in terms of access mechanisms
in global historical Collective
governance are the use of Elections uh
the use of age boundaries and the use of
blood relations and property
requirements so if we look at global
history uh elections certainly play a a
fundamental role but the other systems
of selecting into into assemblies Again
by and large Central non- Elite
assemblies are systems that we actually
associate with more oligarchical perhaps
uh structures uh today
okay all right everyone still with me
all right you're still nodding which is
amazing I I really appreciate it okay
how am I one time ali uh you're good you
have uh 17 more minutes 17 17 that
includes oh okay oh okay so I have two
okay so I'm going to actually go uh
quickly through this uh and this is just
a uh this is something that I spend a
lot of time on which is like okay let's
say that I do these things because I'm a
classical historian by training which is
part of only part of the reason arguably
um and I study historical Collective
governance because U again this is what
a historian someone train as a historian
does I actually think that there's a
little bit more of to it than that and I
think that this evidence is actually
fundamental to understand how to build
institutions today particularly at a
time when sort of like Western
liberalism seems to have to be at the
point of like descendant as opposed to
like ascendance um but the question of
like how to actually use this evidence
to build institutions today is to me not
that obvious and so some of us have been
spending a little bit of time trying to
write about it and trying to think about
it uh my colleague Nathan Sneider and
David Savage at NYU whom I mentioned
earlier uh wrote this like very nice
short piece in NOA where they uh suggest
how lessons from early democracies or uh
historical Collective governance uh uh
communities uh can be uh used to think
about platform regulation um and a
couple of years ago I wrote a sort of a
provocative perhaps piece in wired uh
that uh was sort of meant to use the
example of the Athenian Council uh to
think about uh algorithmic account
accountability so I tend to never
mention that piece to anyone but Ali
knows about it and she asked me to talk
about it so that's it's her fault um
essentially what did you say in the
piece oh look let me tell you all about
it um so this again the the sort of the
provocation uh came from my involvement
in a open AI report that came out in
2020 which for questions of algorithmic
accountability this is equivalent to
ancient history uh the report was on
trustworthy Ai and the report
essentially sort of like summarized the
the question of like how to build
institutions for algorithmic
accountability uh that actually included
some sort of like accountability to the
companies uh in uh with the words like
we should create external auditing
bodies but of course uh the report never
sort of like mentioned what those
auditing bodies uh are to look like and
so the piece was meant to sort of like
provoke people into thinking about how
to use uh historical evidence for um for
for thinking about this kind of
institution building in ungoverned
spaces perhaps uh still ungoverned
certainly in the US um so again the
premises of the piece were the sort of
like a just provoke readers into
thinking about the fundamental clash
between uh the use of algorithms in
society and thinking about democracies
and assemblies in one case you get a a s
an optimization function that tells you
uh this this is the best possible
outcome but of course uh this is not
something that will surprise many of you
in the room this is not how politics
works and in fact based on what might we
might Des describe as the original
lesson of democracy these types of
societal trade-offs are best addressed
by listening to uh varied uh voices by
many voices um and so the the the piece
was sort of like again uh trying to look
at empirical evidence of how large scale
citizen governance on tough questions uh
might occur um and so the the
provocation was to model a uh idealized
Institution for algorithmic
accountability on the Athenian Council
500 and here the devil's in the details
right I want to I I don't want to sort
of bore you too much with this but the
idea here is that the boo featured very
few very interesting rules that in a
sort of like a nice little package uh
ensured broad citizen participation and
representation so let me address some of
the questions that Ali got because the
Athenians seem to have sort of like a
thought about stratification in a
slightly different way which is
essentially over time um and so they uh
used a lot to select people people
across relevant cleavages can talk about
that again until your eyes pop out but
let me not bore you too much they had an
annual mandate so you're in and then
you're out theand cannot be iterated not
not it cannot be iterated consecutively
and in general you cannot iterate the
Mandate for more than two years the
result of this some classical historians
have done the numbers is that a huge
chunk of the Athenian uh um the part of
the population that was eligible for
participation in politics a huge chunk
of that population actually at one point
in their lives participated in this
institution and that had some uh really
interesting sort of like a uh uh knock
on effects uh the uh the the KnockOn
effects are that these rules um enabled
this particular institution to enable
some of the pit to avoid some of the
pitfalls that we normally associate with
Collective governance such as the
possibility of lead capture but also the
idea that Collective governance is just
a bunch of ignorant people in the
athenia case sitting on a hill making
decisions about things that they don't
know anything and therefore that's why
they need experts and the Athenians seem
to have sort like overcome this uh
problem through the system of rules that
promoted knowledge knowledge aggregation
within the institution at a given time
and learning over time so again I don't
want to sort of like uh
spend uh more than I have already spent
in terms of time sort of like trying to
convince you that there is uh something
uh valuable thinking about these uh
historical institutions uh for
institution building today but I hope to
have given you a sense that it is in
fact sort of like a perhaps about time
to think about experiments in Collective
governance that are both past and Global
uh to think about systems of collective
governance that go beyond this sort of
like a real interesting but also
peculiar in my perspective sort of focus
on the lot um and also to think very
very clearly and and sort of like a
clearly uh perhaps about application of
uh this evidence to Modern institution
building I'm going to shut up thank you
for your uh
consideration some of you are still
awake I think
Ali hi I'm Ally serrone you've heard me
talk a lot um so one thing I think
that's interesting about this research
is um one scale so a lot of the people
in this room are trying to figure out
can we scale you know not just
governance but you know different type
of scale but to what extent like you
know can deliberative groups be bigger
can we have multiple of them running can
we start doing thousands of people in
assemblies you know so what what does
your um research teach us about scale
and this kind of goes back to Costa's
question it's interesting because we see
historically a lot of the cool stuff
with lotteries happened in Europe right
but these were also the first
democracies they were they were also uh
easier to govern they were richer you
know there's a lot of like other
correlates that might kind of explain
this but it is the case that even today
so in the US um we have a lot of people
in this room that are doing us-based uh
activities but Europe is by far
surpassing Us in terms of um the
experimentation the novelty and like
having this be routine so people know
about citizens assemblies in Europe the
average American citizen I would argue
uh does not and so uh is there uh is
there a European magic is this kind of
path dependence is there something uh do
you think that the European way can be
exported um yeah so about scale I think
that this is in fact one of the biggest
takeaway from this research is to push
against the idea that there is something
uh about small scale that favors
Collective governance and something
about large scale that makes it
impossible um and I again I think that
the the devil's in the details here I'm
not going to say that that fundamental
assumption about the sort of like what
makes Collective governance flourish is
uh falsified by what I'm seeing what I'm
seeing is in fact that Collective
governance institutions occur at any
scale in a poli from very very small to
pretty large um and what seems to be
particularly uh relevant is the ways in
which they are nested within other
institutions so I think that this is in
fact something that the database can
really give us because we are not going
to have a Congress of Lottery elected uh
participants and so I think that the
question for us is not so much to think
about substitution but to think about
like ways in which we can integrate
systems of collective governance within
other hierarchical representative and
various types of Institutions so scale
to me is a red herring per se but the
the real question is about like
articulation of various types of
Institutions with potentially very
different mechanisms of selection of
decision- making and so on and so forth
and again I don't think that we're going
to uh get much past that uh even I
almost already ideal uh version of uh
doing politics I think that
participation has a role to play but not
everywhere perhaps and this is again
like the social science that we need is
really about these questions so that's
uh that's about scale on Europe well I
think that Europe has that's that's
interesting I don't know but the answer
to your question is I don't know but I
think that Europe has a a long-term
tradition of uh types and forms of
collective governance it also has of
course for a variety of reasons uh
political fragmentation is something the
political scientists love to think about
all the time um a uh sort of like a a
more uh like an like ease with uh less
hierarchical forms of governance um I
don't think that the United States is in
a particularly sort of like a uh
different position um and I think that
there's actually quite a bit of
experimentation in the US it's just us
look so much bigger um and I think that
it's also probably true that um I wonder
if that is correct like what are the
expectations of the average European
Citizen First of the average American
citizen I think that they change also
dramatically so I'm not quite sure that
it is true that the average European
citizen knows about citizen assemblies
in the way that but I don't know this is
like my complete speculation I think
that there is something historical about
that favored the the historical creation
of collective governance in Europe but
again I think that there is a lot of
evidence that suggest that Collective
governance is not just European
phenomenon we're just not looking at it
um and so again the the the project here
uh goes into the quite thorny question
of how to elicit that evidence which is
usually couched in um uh or or um
accessible through uh much more hard to
access uh processes uh sometimes
involving World histories and interviews
and so on and so forth um and that's
where we're going but that's going to be
a kind of warms so to speak yes H Chris
I guess you're hi um my name is Chris
I'm with meta and really appreciated
hearing more about your um your studies
and also really enjoyed your wired
article um and really excited to talk
more about that as well I would just
note that at meta we are ahead of open
AI in deliberative discourse um just
just a a friendly plug um but I guess as
we as you talk about scaling I think to
follow up on the question on scaling
Something That We're super interested
in um I am
curious uh as you looked at um data on
deliberative discourse or mechanisms
outside of Europe um you highlighted
like some various kind of ways that
people structured their
deliberation um understanding that
there's a dir of data or just less data
or less examples I guess I'm just
wondering do you think is it from a
scaling perspective does there need to
be a difference in selection or do you
also think in terms of the the structure
of the
deliberation um again understanding that
there's not as much data but like is
there as as scaling moves toward towards
more inclusion in the in the global
South in
particular does there need to be an
adjustment um in the actual model of
deliberation yeah so this is this is I
think where this uh uh um result is most
most interesting um this is it so the
idea that there are different mechanisms
so in a in a best case scenario what
this on the on the on the Y AIS you
would mechanisms here and so what you're
seeing here is in fact mechanisms that
operate in different differently sized
communities um the data here is too
terrible to draw any conclusion really
um and it would be like sort of a little
bit absurd for me to to um to to tell
you things that I actually I can't
really say but what this result tells us
is that it is precisely this kind of
question that we should ask uh this is
clearly indicating that for the
communities that we have in the data set
different mechanisms of access of
decision making I'll get to deliberation
in a second but selection decision
making enforcement of decisions vary
across siiz uh groups and so uh that
might be you know one of that will be
one of the things that we try to um uh
investigate further just to be clear we
don't really H we have Del deliberation
is one of the decision- making
mechanisms but it is not by far the only
one um so it is one of about uh 100
mechanisms thanks um I wonder so you
know one of the things about having um
clustering of of uh decision-making
processes or Collective governance
institutions is it raises questions
about diffusion right so you know it's
not just Athens right it's a whole bunch
of Greek uh uh poises po whatever um and
so I wonder to what extent um the data
set as it exists now or as as you plan
to make it would tell us about diffusion
networks what what can we infer about
this stuff it's very interesting how you
know we have uh a whatever a thousand
years without Lots in Europe and then it
pops up in in Venice and I'm sure given
the way that these types of things work
people are talking about and thinking
about Greece in Venice um and likewise
today when people talk about in rooms
like this when people talk about l they
point back to Athens so I wonder what
what you have to yeah no this is a great
question and we are uh the next thing
that we're going to be doing is a
clustering analysis that's going to tell
us in fact if we have neighboring
effects or clustering effects of this
kind particularly at the level of the
region um or not uh because that St that
analysis should tell us as if we do have
this type of like a diffusion of
Institutions within a sort of like a
geographic region or sub region like we
see in Greece for example that is a very
striking in fact that is so striking
that as a classical historian and so
knowing pretty much what I'm doing in
that particular context I had to uh take
the Greek police and essentially squeeze
them into two entries in the data set
I've got Athens for which we have an
enormous amount of evidence and I've got
Greek democracies and I've got then I've
got Greek oligarchies and if I were to
code all of them I would have 3,000
cases in Europe and nothing for any of
the other regions so th those
neighboring effects and clustering
effects at the level of the region are
already evident in this grouping which
by the way we're going to have to sort
of disaggregate in in some way but what
we're trying to do now is actually
trying to sort of be agnostic about the
existence of uh those clusters and run a
clustering analysis and see what in what
in fact uh whether in fact it is
regional uh diffusion or something else
entirely that is driving similarity
across
communities thank you that's great and
with that we're actually out of time
okay great thank
[Applause]
you